peu
[Musique]
ce jour là
14 juin 1925 à quand un homme dont la
tournure élégante avait quelque chose de
parisiens traverse à la place des
acacias et se dirigea vers la boutique
de l'armurier andré mes notes
julie la femme de l'armurier était
considérée comme la plus jolie personne
de camp et les badauds venait volontiers
la lorgner au grand déplaisir de madame
schwartz la femme du commissaire de
police qui habitait au premier étage de
la même maison mais présentement on a
dit mireille à un curieux objet que
l'armurier avait exposé à sa devanture
c'était un brassard de milan du 14e
siècle gantelet avec poigne et articulé
et avant-bras cloud et de rubis et
vigoureusement ciselé bien fait pour
attirer les regards
[Musique]
mais note lui aussi est un maître
verrier cette pièce avec un lot de
vieilles ferrailles parler d'une aubaine
pour lui et l'a restauré maintenant ils
pourraient la rendre une réponse est oui
il ne rêve fortune
le métal est noble or et argent brûlé
l'a6 bure est rare et rien que les
pierres enrichir et un homme à monsieur
de la partie oui
dites moi c'est donc nous sommes votre
armuriers semer mainate monsieur n'est
pas d'ici et non je passe je voyage
andre miller s'est installé à caen il y
a deux ans ils s'aimaient ramasser les
vieux pistolet les vieux fusil les
vieilles gp il a réparé frotter astiquer
il a lancé la mode des collections
d'armes
on met cela sur les murs dans les salons
ça fait très bien mais nos tel mal
clientèle on dit même qu'il compte faire
le voyage de paris pour vendre son
brassard au directeur du musée du louvre
mais je vois à pour un étranger on peut
dire qu'il a bien réussi
regarde c'est un étranger monsieur il
vient doit assez sur lui me dit d'être
bien de la corse comme napoléon dix mois
il n'a pas peur qu'on lui vole son
brassard personne ne s'y hasardent
aurait monsieur le commissaire de police
schwartz habite dans la maison pour
premier acte et le voisinage procès
entre des voleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si l'on songe et enlever andré mais note
quelques trésors ce ne serait pas celui
ci monsieur bah quoi d'autre sa femme
monsieur la belle julie cette madone
italienne
[Musique]
n'est ce pas qu'elle est belle on vient
de loin pour la contempler et dites moi
et elle ça j'adore c'est faux dit
virginie voilà mme la commissaire a fait
fort jalouse
autrefois c'est elle qu'on admirait
junon rival de venice on sait bien qu'il
préférait monsieur j'ai bien leur
précieuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment va bonheur
que fait-on dans la patrie du boeuf gras
comme on se rencontre tout de même c'est
vrai même si le coq on se rencontre
comme ça et tu es toujours chez monnier
frère non ce qu'ils ont dit que j'étais
remercier chez monnier frère en ont
menti jean-bapiste on ne prend pas cette
heure contre 1 ne t'inquiète pas pour
moi enfin puisqu'on merci le coq le coq
le fils adoptif d'un colonel non monnier
d'un minable et je lui ai tiré ma
révérence
j'avais quatre mille chènevis berti les
compagnies m'ont offert 5 mg et
commission emballé 5000 et les
commissions qui a bien fait de quitter
cette baraque
je n'ai pas quitté on a réduit le nombre
des employés chez pas de bonheur comme
vous et moi monsieur coke dans le
commerce il ya un nid bonheur dit
malheur ce qui compte c'est la façon de
tenir les cartes et de risquer le tout
que fait-on attaquants
à ton dîner seulement
ne ment pas jean baptiste tu me
raconteras ta vie à table
[Musique]
alors moments volés on nous l'avons de
tarte aux pommes
j'honore à la mitraille fidèles avaient
brûlé n'oubliez pas mon carrosse à 8h
heure militaire je sois alençon demain
matin ici on me donnerais ardoises du
toit à crédit l'ensemble bonhomme on
comptait sur l'aide de monsieur le
commissaire schwartz qui est notre
cousin la mode de bretagne d'alsace
michel bock tous les schwarzenegger
populaire ils sont tous parents mais il
y avait déjà quelqu'un en place dans la
maison du prochain commissaire
si j'étais venu seulement la semaine
dernière c'est moi qui serai maintenant
secrétaire la barre à habas vivons donc
pour nous consoler alors comme ça comme
ça en a tant besoin d'argent
eh oui as tu vu dans cinq de cette
auberge jean baptiste au coq hardi
je suis le coq et je suis a redit en
déboutonnant nous j'ai peut-être besoin
de vous bonhomme et je paye comptant je
suis enfant j'ai livré avant-hier à
monsieur ben c'est le plus gros
banquiers de caen un coffre fort a
secret muni d'une défense ingénieuse le
tout dernier modèle un vrai piège au
voleur
ça m'a fait une fameuse commission mais
qu'est ce que vous payez comptant
un service tant que service et aboie
donc à entrer rapidement brûlé
tu le coq hardi moins trois partout
jolies tenues par l'élégant facilité
d'élocution et le reste bref il ya
quelque part une femme qui m'attend
cette nuit mais il faut que je fasse
semblant quitter la ville c'est une
femme mariée
tu comprends jean baptiste à nos âges
on n'est pas de bois certes avec les
femmes mariées s'agit pas de présenter
le code alors n'y allez pas voilà bien
la netteté est la sienne mais si j'irai
les précautions sont prises
tout à l'heure je pars au vu et au su de
tous les villageois il ya en ce moment
une lettre signée - qui voyagent en aval
poste elle sera demain jeter dans la
boîte d'alençon à l'adresse du pape a
brûlé le patron de l'auberge nous sommes
en ce moment pour lui réclamer ma canne
à pommeau d'argent que tu vois là dans
le coin et que je vais oublier en
partant oublié
comprends-tu tout ça pour une âme watts
c'est drôle ça ressemble aux histoires
qu'on lit dans les journaux
comment est ce qu'il appelle ça déjà la
cour d'assises fondane alibi je crois
bravo on fera quelque chose de toi à
madame oui le mot juste un alibi et pour
le fignoler le rendre inattaquable au
cas où le mari vous l'aurez me crée des
désagréments je te paye 100 francs
comptant un mot que tu diras ce soir
tout doucement à l'oreille de ton cousin
le commissaire de police qui est un ami
intime du mari merci pour le dilemme
chez lecoq maire aux affaires ne me
regarde pas
je ne ferai jamais rien qui m'expose on
ne donne pas son front pour un rendez
vous il ya autre chose mais si c'est la
dame qui fait les frais voyons c'est
simple ce soir monsieur le commissaire
schwartz ira grossir franconie avec son
épouse
c'est dans les devoirs de sa charge
chaque franconie pour cinq ans 10h30
il rentrera chez lui tu sais place des
acacias puis de trouve sur son passage
il te dit encore toi là dessus explique
que dépourvue de fond tu comptais sur
l'obligeance d'un ancien collègue le coq
celui qui représente la maison berthier
et compagnie et qui a fourni le coffre
fort a secret de l'honorable monsieur
bancel tu diras que le coq a quitté
l'hôtel du coq hardi ce soir pour
alençon dans son équipage emporte en ta
dernière chance aux commissures temps
les rats promener pour n'avoir pas
ouvrir sa bourse
mais il sera que je suis loin depuis un
bout de temps c'est la seule chose qui
compte
il faut qu'ils me sache partie as tu
saisis qu'est ce qui le chagrine c'est
pas un mensonge thèmes arrangements de
la vérité et où paraîtra normal si je
savais qu'il ya rien d'autre chose que
de l'amour là dessous non je suppose
bonhomme que vous ne respectez ni mon
honneur ni mes convictions politiques
est-ce que vous donnez des arts pas un
chiffrement nos hésitations me
déplaisent
si je faisais la chose ou est ce que je
vous rejoindrai bravo il fera jour
demain écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
pendant que monsieur le coq était occupé
à son affaire qui n'était peut-être pas
d'amour
l'armurier mes notes parlait à sa femme
de la caisse de monsieur bancel
toute la ville se préoccupait au moins
autant que de son brassard
le banquier l'avait appelé pour lui
demander de faire de ce coffre à secrets
un bijou on ciselant les boutons et
andorrans les moulures
mais julie rey veut écouter à peine
entré lui expliquer la mécanique qui au
premier tour de clef donnée par un homme
de connaissant par le chiffre se
déclenchait au dessus de la serrure pour
serrer le bras du voleur dans ses
griffes
justement sub ans elle avait par mais
son coffre car il venait d'y mettre
beaucoup d'argent aux marchands julie
sortie de ses songes et demanda curieuse
y at il beaucoup d'argent dans la caisse
à tout en échéance du 15 et le prix de
son château du bord de mer en tout plus
de 400 mille francs
on a montré les billets de banque il m'a
dit que personne ne couchera côté de la
caisse il est très fier de sa mécanique
on dirait qu'il a envie de tenter un
voleur pour l'éprouver plus de 400 mille
francs s'affiche très riche le nak trois
ans je ne connais pas encore la valeur
de l'argent
il ya quelqu'un dans la boutique
le 14
1825 à caen après avoir contemplé un
brassard 6 les exposés dans la vitrine
de l'armurier andré menottes un voyageur
de commerce parisien monsieur le coq
s'est arrangé un alibi pour un prétendu
rendez-vous damman le soir andry mes
notes par là sa femme julie du coffre
fort a secret contenant 400 mille francs
il a vu chez le banquier bancel ils
entendent un bruit bizarre dans sa
boutique il ya quelqu'un dans la
boutique
oria c'était le ca les commissaires
farce laporte avait mal fermé qui fait
chaud ce soir c'est nous sortirons vers
près de la place nous fera du bien avant
de nous coucher autorisant on sera mieux
dehors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
francony c'est toujours la même chose
des gugusses des contorsionnistes je
suis morte dans l'ue
[Musique]
on
tuer son jeu ce soir qu'à dessus je
m'ennuie du petit bond nous iront le
voir demain chez madeleine se trouve
soucieuse tu essaies de me cacher
quelque chose quand tu crois je t'aime
je suis heureuse avec toi je te crois
quelquefois je pense que tu n'es pas né
pour être la femme d'un ca partisans
te sens un petit peu exilés ce monde qui
est elle tient quitte à portet l'argent
le luxe
[Musique]
mais parlons plus du passé il faut
rester loin de ces gens qui nous
haïssent
parce que je pense à ce monde j'y perds
tu as raison pensons à l'avenir
nous avons débuté ici avec ses 3000
francs que j'apportais de corse
nous avons eu nos petits succès dans
cette boutique est à paris seulement on
peut arriver à la fortune nous allons
partir pour paris andré à tes yeux
brillent à paris tu auras la vie dont tu
rêves écoute hier soir l'armée rudy
gossin m'a offert douze mille francs
pour mes marchandises de ma clientèle
est monsieur bancel peux m'acheter le
brassard police
il prétend que c'est un instrument qui
peut permettre à un homme rusé de mettre
la main dans la mécanique sans être
mordu il préfère la voir chez lui sous
un globe
il ment nov 6000 francs
[Musique]
debout les semaines qui viennent et
aborde et je crois que tu l'avait
éconduit une bonne voie en forme ce
commissaire
on ferme adam combative ans je porte le
brassard demain matin celle ci pense m
quant à la vente du magasin regarde ces
faits et la a36 on pense là thierry
auneau furent ont-elles encore bertrand
vous avez fait peur à ma femme henry a
beau être pensent ils soient de riz et
souffre la lumière et je vous souhaite
une bonne nuit produits dérivés
[Musique]
après avoir en parlant aux commissaires
schwartz assurer la limite monsieur
lecoq jean baptiste dit à la vie il
paraissait plonger dans des réflexions
mélancolique
le lendemain matin ce 15 juin 1825
monsieur lecoq reparu d'un endroit où il
avait caché sa carriole
il revenait de temps
mais fallait il vraiment s'habiller en
paysans pour aller à un rendez vous
d'amour
monsieur lecoq avait fait de longs
détours pour éviter les métairies
dispersés dans la campagne
il n'en était pas à sa première affaire
mais celle-ci lui tenait beaucoup à
coeur
[Musique]
il fit une rapide toilettes et repris la
route
je
oh
[Musique]
à
un croisement de chemins un homme
attendait à six unités
jean baptiste 11 charte avait la mine de
quelqu'un qui n'a pas fermé l'oeil
contre il est vrai que toute la nuit il
avait songé aux 100 francs progrès en se
demandant si monsieur lecoq s'était pas
mobile en batiste j'ai mon petit doigt
qui me raconte des histoires y a bien
fait ma comme ici en bonhomme
mon cousin le commissaire ni avec du fun
voix non non moi tu ne vas pas loin
moi je suis en ce moment à alençon olic
parce que j'ai de rhume et demain matin
je me lèverai dix ponts z ont peur du
marine si le coq meti drôles ou produit
le mari allez allez va craquer nous
sommes pressés je viens de le dire jean
baptiste maintenant qu'ils ont fait jour
il n'y avait pas plus de mari qui est
dans le creux de ma main je m'en doutais
on est pas un est celle qu'elle mine
alsacienne moquer reproduit la manette
et dire que vous m'aviez promis 100
francs parce que je vous ai rendu un
service pour le cas où le mari vous
inquiétez pas c'est juste c'est juste il
n'y a pas de mari et s'en donne 1000
milles et pourquoi me donnez vous me
prendre je veux savoir du mans animal
qui n'a qu'une envie c'est de ne pas
savoir
qu'avez-vous fait cette nuit monsieur
comme le vin le jeu les belles à ses
causes et des saint jean baptiste c'est
vrai je suis content de vous vous êtes
un fameux bonhomme à votre façon
vous avez rendu un service de 1000
francs et je ne veux rien vous de voir
si vous mille francs nous sommes 6
c'est bon c'est bon on ramassera quand
je serais parti on est dans une position
délicate honnête ça ne fait pas de doute
mais on a menti aux commissaires de
police
et si les choses tournaient mal on
serait une invitation
porté par les gendarmes c'est trop tard
bonhomme
la chose est faite mais on ne veut pas
de mal
allez votre chemin tout droit c'est le
meilleur moyen de ne pas voir ce qui se
passe par derrière
bouchez vous les oreilles pour avoir
l'esprit en paix vous étiez pauvres vous
voilà avec un capital si vous êtes sages
vous tripot trévois mille francs comme
un ange et vous deviendrez banquiers
monsieur l'alsacien de guebwiller si
vous n'êtes pas sages vous aurez d'un
côté la police de l'autre moi et ceux
qui en mangent
il comprend pas jean baptiste k2 corde
au cou qu'elles soient tranquilles et
pour toi
il fera jour demain voilà pour voyager
il ne vaut mieux pas changé un gros
billet dans ce pays si quand en effet
comme vous êtes pour la diligence et
file à paris il ya des yeux et des
oreilles partout et
jean baptiste schwartz était d'honnête
ils avaient une conscience la vue de cet
argent lui faisait presque horreur
quelque chose lui criait un crime est là
la figure de lecocq lui apparut alors
grandi à une taille diabolique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
en
[Musique]
andré mes notes avaient passé la nuit
sans repos l'idée d'abandonner la
province pour tenter sa chance à paris
l'idée de rendre enfin à julie la vie
agréable pour laquelle elle était faite
l'avait empêché de dormir
il était à la fois joyeux et inquiet le
veto il contempla juil
comme elle était belle
[Musique]
il entra dans la petite pièce qui lui
servait d'atelier il avait envie de voir
le jour peut-être que lui j'en suis
convaincu
j'ai bien examiner la question ça ne
peut être qu andré menottes qui a pu
faire le coup de paris une nouvelle ou
réveil boncelles parle de se brûler la
cervelle que vas tu faire arrêter ce
mais notent tous l'accusent le brassard
qui était dans sa vitrine est resté
coincé dans les griffes qui protège la
serrure de la caisse bancel et comme fou
dit que c'est sa faute
ils allaient tous racontent l armurier
nous l'a montré son argent voulu acheter
le brassard parce que c'était une
protection pour les voleurs
maintenant il se reproche de lui avoir
donné l'idée le travail a été fait par
deux personnes il fallait quatre mains
pour forcer le coffre
la moitié de la besogne aurait peut être
fait par un enfant par une femme a
toujours dit qu'il fallait se méfier de
ces gens là alors tous les a vus hier
soir bandes noires
assis sur le banc complétait un trio
bertrand m'a dit qu'ils les avaient
surpris
il les a entendus qui parlait de la
caisse de pension et il comptait des
billets de banque
courthieu il faut les arrêter tout de
suite rassure toi une conversation
entendue par la fenêtre chez son voisin
le commissaire schwartz fait comprendre
à andré mes notes qu'on le soupçonne
d'avoir cambriolé avec sa femme julie le
coffre fort du banquier bancel grâce à
un brassard ciselé que toute la ville
avait pu voir dans sa vitrine
andré ne peut savoir qu'il est victime
d'une machination organisée par le
mystérieux monsieur lecoq le brassard a
disparu la maison est cernée par des
gendarmes fait
avec toi vite yat il parle pas il faut
partir je t'expliquerai plus tard martin
[Musique]
il
julie l'exploit habille toi si tu
m'aimes comme on pouvait l'avoir le
comme en métropole a failli introduite
en mai après ces faits les blacks à son
avoine
[Musique]
bien joli
dépêche toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah les yeux
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
nous sommes sauvés si tu fais que tu
dansais sommes sauvés
je suis heureux je t'aime ou men tu
espères tu c'est un jeu d'enfant se
cache un jour deux jours ne pas me
cacher que d'un jour sont maintenant à
deux heures deux camps ne nommerons pas
tout de suite les crises cette femme
cette course je me suis crue morte
qu'avons nous à craindre quelque chose
de terrible
mais le premier danger est passé chef
je ne comprends pas tu me dis qu'il faut
craindre et pourtant tu as l'air si
tranquille mais pas peur
[Musique]
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas rester là
comme si tout était normal
explique moi que tu fais mais rien je te
le jure
rien
[Musique]
regarde comme il fait beau c'est
souvient du jour à certaines coutu
consenti à me suivre
moi artisans sans fortune et toi si
noble est si riche
c'était un jour pareil à celui ci je me
souviens j'étais mais je t'aime toujours
comme ce journal
[Musique]
nous étions poursuivis
et ce qui nous poursuivaient et est
implacable
en avion que notre amour mais ce but
assez puisque nous leur avons échappé
[Musique]
quand nous avons attendu le cadeau de
leur jeu bourg sur la route
dumas qui veut nous étions cachés
rappelle-toi la force qui était en nous
c'est de là bas on retrouve une autre
trace non ce n'est pas cela il faut que
tu sois forte comme s'ils étaient ce
jour
[Musique]
cette nuit
on a volé 400 mille francs dans la
caisse de monsieur bancel nous sommes
accusés
oui nous et ma conviction est faite nous
sommes condamnés d'avancé et paris est
le seul endroit au monde où j'espère te
cacher car je ne veux pas que tu sois
jeté en prison pourquoi partie de prison
je crois en tonnes innocence comme je
suis sûr de la mienne hier soir quand
nous avons entendu ce bruit dans le
magasin quelqu'un est venu voler le
brassard j'ai tout compris maintenant
c'est avec ce brassard que les voleurs
ont forcé la caisse de monsieur bancel
ils étaient deux mois seul savait que le
coffre contenait une véritable fortune
le commissaire schwartz n'a vu dehors et
le père bertrand a dit que nous
comptions des billets de banque mais
c'est en argent on ne peut pas croire
monsieur quotien tira médias dans cette
affaire trop de fait contre nous alors
qu'à pour de fusion dans l'ensemble je
te suivrai partout
allons chercher notre fille sur
madeleine mais tu l'as dis toi même on
se cache un jour ou deux non mon père
m'a laissé un an sans tache et je veux
léguer à mon fils tu espères dont alors
pourquoi me chasser pourquoi ta fuite de
ce matin mais pour pouvoir combattre il
faut que je te met à l'abri comprends tu
quand tu seras à paris le serai fort une
fois le danger passé je te rejoins dray
doit bien exister quelques loups verts
pour éclaircir ce mystère
je la découvre irais je me bats tu soit
salie par leurs soupçons ont traîné
devant un tribunal
moi je tiens vedette jeremy libre et
de loin tu me soutiendra
[Musique]
et
j'ai bien ri gun
[Musique]
comment elle est à paris j'ai commandé
cacher tu vas changer de vêtements je m
attends que ces deux paysannes qui est
dans la valise je vais te conduire à la
diligence de paris je te laisserais tout
l'argent et mon fils tu ne peux pas les
emmener ce serait un indice comprend à
paris du sras le jeune fille alors qu'on
cherchera une femme une mère de toute
confiance en maternelle n'est ce pas
elle gardera notre enfant des sacs sont
là voici l'argent
[Musique]
tu reprendras ton nom de jeune fille
julien marie arena
tu ne t'es jamais mes alliés il n'a
jamais épousé
andré menotti à paris tu iras chez son
oncle colonel baudot
ce sera secourable puisque tu n'as pas
besoin de faire appel à sa fortune on
n'écrit pas cela exposerait moi je
t'écrirai si je peux attendons de tuléar
henny bos de restaurants ne perdent
jamais espoir
attends moi
tu n'es pas
[Musique]
je serai fort pour toi elle pour notre
enfant
[Musique]
pour m
il faudra que madeleine aime beaucoup
non non ce n'est pas possible andré
andré ne m'en vois pas paris juillet
rappelle-toi sartène je ne veux pas que
tu pleures
je t'appellerai la diligence qui
arrivait de caen s'apprêtait à repartir
pour paris jeudi à maria rennais je vais
à paris on assemble jean-baptiste-lebas
[Applaudissements]
opran fille s'affairent à paris merci
monsieur le déguisement kfw prix julie
mes notes ne pouvait altérer sa boîte et
et jean baptiste schwartz ont reçu d'une
profonde impression
monsieur lecoq n'avait pas prévu cette
rencontre met le bazar de ses caprices
[Applaudissements]
ah les blacks nous retournons à l'écurie
clair tout de suite je ne suis pour rien
dans toute cette histoire monsieur le
commissaire je venais au marché je monte
ici place des acacias pour leur donner
des nouvelles du petit et blanc on tombe
dessus comme si j'étais une cellule je
vous ai simplement retenu parce que j'ai
besoin de votre témoignage
vous êtes la nourrice de l'enfant est
bien savoir quelque chose je ne sais
rien il était gentil tous les deux
honnête je vous reconnais pas de famille
dit est-ce que je peux regarder le petit
rien ne s'y oppose
seulement si les parents venaient le
chercher il faudrait m'avertir tu veux
les laisser à la voisine
peut-être qu'en ce moment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on saluera tu as voulu doubler le cheval
et la voiture volée
[Musique]
je
le
[Musique]
dans la nuit du 14 au 15 e à 1825
on a dérobé quatre cent mille francs
chez un banquier de caen monsieur bancel
en se servant pour venir à bout du
mécanisme de défense de son coffre-fort
d'un brassard de métal anciens
appartenant à l'armurier andré mes notes
en précédant fui avec sa femme julie
soupçonné d'être un complice il a voulu
la mettre à l'abri avant de se présenter
devant le commissaire de police
schwartz il ne sait pas comment prouver
son innocence
[Musique]
j appris la diligence de paris en même
temps que le jeune jean-baptiste
schwartz dit sans le savoir a joué un
rôle sous la direction d'un certain
monsieur le coq dans la machination dont
sont victimes les menottes avec la furie
il a surtout peur de nager doucement et
4000 francs
thonnel attaché le cas dès le mois
d'août une des courses qui mérite les
éloges
qu'est-ce que tu te charivari signifie
n'oubliez pas que vous êtes devant le
représentant de l'ordre dans cette ville
alors messieurs alors je viens vous
parler monsieur le commissaire de mon
plein gré la celle
gd revolver qu'il avait sur lui ouais
votre femme
je les conduis à la côte elle est partie
pour l'angleterre
je mets la disposition de la justice
nous sommes innocents mais comme un dans
madame star je vous prie de regagner
notre appartement
c'est bon je vous arrête aurait conduit
en prison
nous sommes innocents m'abonne madeleine
les malheurs ils disent tous car de
tin-tin ce pauvre monsieur n'est pas en
cause alors vous non plus madeleine vous
ne me croyez pas
emmenez lot vous comprenez bien que vous
êtes mais vous même en position de
coupables en fuyant en faisant passer
votre femme en angleterre monsieur le
juge
un jour en cour d'assises j'ai vu une
jeune femme près de son mari
salis par les regards de la foule j'ai
trouvé cette scène ignominieuse
intolérable c'est ce que j'ai voulu
éviter à julie vous exprimez bien vous
avez reçu de l'instruction il ya en vous
quelque chose mais il faut nous en tenir
au fait monsieur est malheureusement les
faits vous accable l'argent que vous
comptiez votre femme l'emporté avec elle
on assure qu'elle a des goûts de luxe au
dessus de son état il y avait douze
mille provenant de la vente de mon
commerce vous avez le témoignage de
monsieur gaussin mais rien ne prouve que
les quatre cent mille francs volés à
monsieur bancel ne se sont pas ajoutés
ces douze mille francs là pourquoi
serais je reve nus alors avec cette
forte nous aurions été à l'abri j'aurais
pu aussi emmener mon enfant ainsi c'est
le prévenu qui joue à embarrasser le
juge
tout cela pourrait n'être qu'un coup
d'audace
le plan d'un homme très intelligent je
savais que je serais arrêté ma
conscience était tranquille mais je
voyais surgir des circonstances capable
d'égaler la justice ce brassard qu'on
m'a volé c'est vous qui le dites je le
dis en effet je la firme sous serment
quelqu'un s'est introduit dans ma
boutique pour prendre ce brassard est ce
quelqu'un est le voleur de monsieur
bancel voyons monsieur le juge
si nous avions comme il se vole ma femme
et moi pourquoi serions nous rentrer
tranquillement chez nous pour dormir au
risque d'être pris à notre réveil j'ai
pensé j'ai tenu le même raisonnement
mais vous étiez le seul à savoir ce que
contenait le coffre-fort et vous saviez
aussi que personne ne regardait mais
monsieur bancel voulez vous acheter
votre brassard d'acier parce qu'ils en
avaient peur vous deviez le lui porter
le lendemain il était donc opportun
d'opérer cette nuit là même vous aviez
vendu votre petit commerce d'une manière
assez précipité cette clé cette clé si
semblables à celles qui ouvrent la
serrure du coffre voyant andre
un artisan comme vous je dirais même un
artiste peut parfaitement forger des
clés à partir d'une empreinte à la cire
et vous aviez travaillé chez monsieur
bancel la veille et le jour même
je ne suis pour rien dans ce vol je suis
un honnête homme
le système de défense ne réussira pas
bien qu'il ne manque ni de convenance
did adresse pour l'admettre il faudrait
supposer un homme ou plutôt un démon
poussant la scélératesse jusqu'au génie
et se préoccupant au moment même où il
commettait son crime
des moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour
égarer la justice est ce là votre idée
je ne sais pas je sens un mystère un
traquenard peut être organisé je me suis
livrée pour qu'on y voit plus clair
l'instruction s'y emploie j'ai fait je
lave ou cette spéculation
un homme mardi exploitant cette fatalité
judiciaire il faut un coupable pour dire
lui il ne faut qu'un coupable
l'instrument employés pour mettre la
main dans la caisse vous accuse vous et
pas un autre
mes investigations ont devancé vos
soupçons deux hommes pouvaient nous être
suspect vous d'une façon évidente
l'autre l'autre et ce voyageur de
commerce qui a vendu le coffre à
monsieur bancel et qui bien qu'ignorant
la combinaison choisie par le banquier
avait le moyen d'en faire fonctionner la
serrure lui les clés vous le brassard
j'ai suivi cette piste
monsieur le coq était absent de camp à
l'heure du vol
son alibi et solide des villageois l'ont
vu quitter la ville en plein jour
plusieurs heures avant le vol pour
alençon son aubergiste affirment l'avoir
vu partir un jeune homme de bonne
famille le cousin du commissaire
schwartz de passage ce jour là dans la
ville nous a permis de vérifier le
sérieux de cet alibi
rien à dire tout se tient et monsieur le
coq et en dehors de la sphère il ne
reste que vous rendrez mes notes
alors je suis perdu nous ne sommes ni la
cour ni le jury nous sommes
l'instruction vous aurez des juges je te
dis tout majuli au jour le jour et tu
vois nous en sort
ces papiers que je mouille des mails à
ce journal de ma captivité
si tu le lises est de permettrait-il à
toi tu y voir clair
dessus entre les mains du juge
d'instruction sur roland c'est un homme
doux et bienveillant on égare ils me
voient parfois tels que je suis mais il
lui arrive de me prendre pour un
scélérat très habile est obligé de s'en
tenir aux profs qui m'accable il m'a dit
tout à l'heure je serai jugé à la
session qui va s'ouvrir dans quelques
jours on m'a donné un défenseur d'office
m cotentin de la loire de l'huile est
venu me voir tout à l'heure c'est un
jeune homme qui veut celui ci je réussis
renseignements par louis mon geôlier qui
m'a pris en amitié
[Musique]
julie j'ai peur
je suis toujours à mon idée qui devient
l'obsession de ma fièvre
ils ont le coupable sous la main tous
parés des preuves qui le condamne
celui qui a eu la pensée de laisser mon
brassard dans les griffes de la machine
à tuer à voir aussi la pensée de me
laisser entre les serres de la justice
moi et pas un autre inconnu un démon m'a
choisi comme bouc émissaire ce que
j'appelle mon idée julie c'est la
vengeance de notre pays corse
si les ennemis de notre amour
derrière cette horrible machination vous
apportez du papier et de lancôme bibi
sur la provision à m cuisez où on lui
raconte cette femme trouvera rien contre
moi là dedans si on vous a chargé de me
faire parler de façon à la bête qu'est
ce qui vous demande vos secrets
je veux bien obligé les gens moi c'est
dans ma nature si vous avez une bonne
tête aller s'avoue soulagé clair nos
amours n'ont mangé le mobile
vous aviez de l'argent caché pour
améliorer l'ordinaire
vous trouvez les relations d'or l'habit
noir lui fut mais les cigares les plus
belles jantes à la baignoire
la fia lyon qu'à l'âge est là où vous
êtes
ça fait du temps il entretenait une
correspondance suivie avec des personnes
comme il faut 10 il manigance et les
choses
il veut avoir des relations importantes
jusque dans la hotte police parce qu'il
est sorti pour de bon et par la grande
porte et salué par monsieur le directeur
s'il vous plaît il ya pas eu de procès
un fait qui était cet homme
l'habit noir je vous dis chez que ça ait
jamais eu ses petits secrets
ils devaient tenir quelque part la
mécanique du grand monde
sans cela ils sont un peu partout ceux
qui en mangent ceux qui en mangent une
association secrète
allez donc savoir humyo pas il faut ré
son nez tout cas et que sa tête de
voyants il est d'ors selectric du fera
t-il jour demain des fois l'innocent
pour la peau du coupable et que voulez
vous dire moi rien
cherien bras et votre voisin lambert là
à côté
il était établi qu'elle artiaco bien
tranquille il ya de ça quelques semaines
les nuls pointe pour une histoire
d'assassinât qui remontait à des années
coincé fait qu'omar a des preuves
partout il ya d'être condamné à mort on
écoutait plus la repartie dans ses rêves
bon bah bonsoy bibi ont selon lui
[Musique]
à
on
en
[Musique]
oh